yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn comm slash yang
[Music]
you must have studied this [ __ ] in
school big-time like there must have
been this whole freakin crazy set a
units odd like the Spanish flu and the
pandemic and the pandemics of the future
and all that stuff yeah I mean that's
the the keyword and epidemiologist is
epidemic III think about an epidemic
like a fire you know if you've got a if
you've got a toaster fire you know you
need to put it out and if you can't put
it out in the toaster it's going to take
over the house
and if you don't put it on the house
it's gonna take over the neighborhood
but imagine all of the stuff we do to
prevent fighters right we've got fire
alarms in our houses we've got fire
stations in our neighborhoods
imagine you were to take the batteries
out of the fire alarm you were to
furloughed the entire firefighting staff
what do you think is gonna happen when
the toaster catches fire and this is
exactly where we were and so we have
created a society where not only did we
actively shut down the capacity to
respond in real-time and put out
outbreaks when they were small but we've
also as you talked quite a bit about
we've created a society where people
were left exceedingly vulnerable to the
economic social political consequences
of something like this happening and so
we were not prepared we were not ready
and it's devastating
[Music]
it's easy old question how do you find
the people you're looking for when
you're looking at hire business and on
the flip side how do you find someone
who's looking for someone just like you
indeed is a great way for both employers
and folks who are looking to take the
next step in terms of finding a job it's
gonna pay the bills keep everyone's head
above the water so when Andrew and I
were running a campaign we ended up
having to hire hundreds of people in the
matter of two to three weeks
it was the most insane time of campaign
hi I can't tell you how stressed the
staff was and tech platforms like indeed
where our saving grace where you're able
to just find quick talent understand
where they're coming from where they are
their experience their specific
expertise are identified their
professional focuses and filter them
quickly interview hire as fast as
possible so we are big fans of indeed
and without platforms like this I can't
tell you how we were already
we were already breaking things and
moving as fast as we could I can't say
how much Messier would have been on the
campaign so if you're a small business
or medium-sized business looking to hire
and hire fast indeed is the place to go
for sure 375 dollar credit for your
first job coach to give it a try and get
in front of quality candidates go to
indeed.com slash yang that's indeed.com
slash yang juice September 30th 75 bucks
off your first job focus to see whether
it works for you and your business
[Music]
[Applause]
all right in this episode of Yang speaks
I'm going to sit down with the former
professor of epidemiology dr. Abdul el
Syed Abdul really brilliant guy ran for
governor of Michigan and he and I have
become friendly through CNN and also it
turns out that he and my brother were at
Columbia together and you know as funny
is that he put two and two together that
I was my brother's brother if you know
what I mean yeah it's a pretty
ubiquitous name your ought it to some
yeah you'd be like hey that Andrew
Yang's cousin so sit down with with dr.
Abdul else I had to talk about our
healthcare system in a time of CO vid
and what we could or should be doing
there are a couple of things that this
week I think we're all sensing you're
seeing Kovac raid search in 32 states 36
states depending upon the day and the
numbers are staggering there is some
confusion around the fatality rates
where people say look you're seeing
massive spikes and infection rates but
fewer people as a percentage are dying
and some people are using that as like a
positive data point but there are two
reasons to doubt that lower mortality
number one is there's a lag between
infection and mortality by the way that
this virus works that there are several
weeks of someone losing their lung
capacity and then ending up on the
ventilator if you have a ventilator and
so the death rates will be a lagging
indicator behind the infection rates and
number two because this virus is
spreading through a broader swath of the
population you're seeing many more young
people test positive and young people
have lower mortality rates because they
have lower levels of pre-existing
conditions so unfortunately there's
nothing good in my mind going on that
it's not like Oh Crona
somehow getting less leads all like
really the thing to pay attention to is
the top line which is that it's now
ripping through Texas Arizona Florida
and it breaks my heart and infuriates me
when I think about this because at this
point we're all going to be stuck with
community mitigation essentially where
we're all just going to be looking
around saying okay social distance wear
a mask wash my hands avoid indoor
gatherings don't go to gyms don't go to
bars don't go to restaurants and that's
what we individually will do but
collectively as a country the genies out
of the bottle and in this case the genie
is that like terrible destructive genie
where it's wreaking havoc taking lives
destroying ways of life we're going to
be at this for to it to me the
indefinite future until evacs scene
arrives and the vaccine was going to
arrive who knows I mean months at best
you had a tweet the other day Andrew
that I loved and I was trying to pull it
up real quick
here it is we missed the window to test
and trace we missed the window to
suppress and contain now we're faced
with a terrible situation that will
worsen through the summer and fall
without dramatic action action that may
no longer even be possible what a
disaster and you're right and somehow in
this process we've also managed to
politicize it because it seems to me
that the only objective thing that
actually stops the spread besides I
guess avoiding large crowds he's wearing
a freaking mask and apparently that's in
a fringe meant upon people's rights so
the government is allowed to force
people to wear pants in public but if
they enforce a mask that's infringing on
your rights and it's driving me nuts
Andrew because people can't wait a
freakin mask and now we have to keep
suffering through this and I don't know
what your thoughts are on how we've made
this a political issue despite we all
don't want to dive in the damn thing
politicizing mask-wearing is such a an
immoral disaster no it's like the virus
doesn't care
about your politics is just trying to
get from person to person wearing a mask
is considerate to others like not
wearing a mask is just being an
irrational [ __ ] who doesn't care
about other people I mean who the heck
wants that for themselves or for someone
around them you know I get it it's
inconvenient it's uncomfortable like the
suck yeah yeah but but who gives a [ __ ]
I mean really that's like oh there was a
supporter who said something online that
broke my heart where apparently someone
gave their parent and a parent died and
then the young person and in this case
like this posting like the young person
like attended a pool party and like came
back and apparently yeah it was not a
good pool party that's for that way and
you know this is one of the things too I
want to suggest as well it's okay to go
outside it's okay to try and do
something that you enjoy just stay the
[ __ ] away from someone else like it's
conceivable that you can have a pool
party that is perfectly responsible if
for example the only people at that
party are you know the people who like
live in a like a particular area where
they essentially just interacted with
each other
pool party with your neighbor and your
neighbors family and your family
interact all the time and no one goes
anywhere then that's fine you know so
it's not like like there are things that
you can do that are responsible things
are better outdoors than in really to me
like the activities that are completely
irresponsible are not wearing a mask in
public where you're forced to be around
people indoor gatherings bars
restaurants house parties where you know
like it the people are not essentially
folks that you're in essence
cohabitating with and what is
frustrating is like there are plenty of
people following the rules and if we all
follow the rules we would slowly be able
to reopen the economy but we have a
subset of people that end politicians
and leaders that seem to think the rules
don't matter or they're fake news or
their propaganda and so the rest was
following those have to keep following
the rules without the I mean compared to
what
their countries are doing they're slowly
opening back up the United States we're
literally going the opposite direction
we're not like he's a like we're flat
it's not like weird a little slower
we're going the wrong way
it's our the most infuriating because
you see in other countries they got it
under control and then now they're able
to reopen and for us it's an extension
of the first wave and it's growing out
of control and this is before you wind
up with colder weather and a potential
flu season in the fall you know as a
parent we're trying to figure out like
our schools supposed to reopen
I believe Harvard just announced that
all of their classes will be online a
lot of international students are being
told like don't come back to the states
if you're if you're in school which is
very very disruptive and problematic I
mean if I'm those students I'm not sure
I want to come back here anyway because
the odds are your home country as much
lower infection rates than the United
States of America like Europe banned
travelers from the US and I don't blame
them you know it's like a view or Europe
would you let Americans in so so we are
now this hotbed for kovat globally in a
way that people could never have
predicted given that we are
theoretically the richest most advanced
country in the world and Harvard
apparently is gonna charge the same
amount of tuition which is also madness
like isn't half of going to college is
the people you meet in the network you
develop particularly going to Harvard
have a going to Harvard is the network
and frankly interacting and studying and
drinking and creating projects and
businesses and ideas with those people
if you're gonna do it online it should
not be the same price that's insane
and Harvard can do it cuz they can get
away with it because our freakin Harvard
and that's really frustrating
so Andrew it seems to me that the only
good thing that's come out of COBIT
right now is that it's clearly
demonstrating the need for universal
health care right in the sense that we
have a system now where health care side
of employment yet half the country's
lost their job and can't afford a kovat
test theoretically and we're providing
universal testing in some way one of the
things that the coronavirus has laid
bare is that we need to overhaul our
health care system in this country
having healthcare attached to job makes
no sense but no one has a job no one has
any money you know like this is such a
clear call to action that we need to
have some version of Medicare for all
and public health care
I personally it was a fan of Medicare
for all I think that we need to just
have health care as a right of
citizenship in this country it's clearer
now than ever
and we also need to listen to scientists
more and we are thrilled to be able to
sit down with a scientist who ran for
office whose world-class in epidemiology
dr. Abdul Elsayed is a professor of
Epidemiology at Columbia big proponent
of Medicare for all of the fact we need
to revamp our health care system you
free him to Detroit Department of Health
ran for governor of Michigan brilliant
brilliant guy dr. Abdullah Syed
[Music]
Abdul it is so good to see you man
you know we last time we saw each other
was in happier times and we were allowed
out of the house able to go to an actual
office building and commune in real life
but congratulations on the the new book
healing politics you should be really
excited and proud yeah I appreciate that
thank you it's ya know the last time we
got to spend some time it was we were
together in a studio for like eight
hours I think it was and to think you
know even think about doing that in
these times but yeah and I appreciate
you taking a read of the book and I hope
that it speaks to the moment that we're
in right now because I do think that
there's a lot that we have to think
about about how we were before this as
we think about what a new normal ought
to be yeah I couldn't agree more
so Abdul is a former epidemiology
professor at Columbia University so one
of the things he's telling us all about
is what the heck to expect over the next
number of weeks and months and another
thing that I'm doing I have in common is
my brother was a professor at Columbia
at the same time he was it boggled my
mind you know what it was it was one of
our former colleagues and she was like
how did you know that that's Andrew
Yang's brother and I was like wait what
that's crazy
because I remember him being just a
great colleague and a good friend than
somebody I really appreciated admired
you don't have to say that [ __ ] just
gonna use my brother no way man we could
talk trash about I would be like you
know there are some people for whom you
know talking trash is really easy in
some people for whom it's hard your
brother's not somebody easy to talk
trash you body's actually remarkably a
really nice guy yeah he is that's one
reason why it's you would be well you
are one of the small group of people
small group of experts that people are
turning to to ask what comes next in
this coronavirus crisis I mean you ran
the Department of Health in Detroit
yourself so you've been at the
frontlines you've been a physician
obviously of an MD ph.d and your PhDs
and epidemiology is that right that's
right
so what would you say is like we've all
seen the estimates like they're saying
that the
fastest time to develop a vaccine I
believe was four years for the mumps now
people are projecting that this could
get done in 12 to 18 months but then
there would be massive problems in terms
of the manufacturer of let's call that
300 million doses of the vaccine and
then some issues around distributing so
there are some things we might be able
to do prior to the vaccine development
is that correct that's right so you know
the vaccine gives you the opportunity to
basically know that people are immune
because you immunize them and again the
more immune people there are in a
society the less the spread it's because
of the this thing called herd immunity
where your probability of getting
disease is a function of how many people
have the disease around you and if there
are more people who are immune there are
less people who have the disease but
that's right like the only way to do
this safely in the absence of a vaccine
is to a know everybody who is exposed
and therefore immune and B identify
those folks who are not immune and
exposed and isolate them from the rest
of the society so that they're not
spreading it but you've got to be able
to do that scale right and we're nowhere
near being able to do that at scale
because we don't have the personnel and
we don't have the testing capacity I'm
with you man like I think about all of
the terrible missed opportunities and
and delays and lives that have been
destroyed as a result the whole thing is
despicable
it is and I love hearing from someone
like you because you're just science
data and knowledge so I would love to
ask you what you think people should be
bearing in mind right now yeah so you
know right now and were in the midst of
mass social distancing we missed the
opportunity to do what's called contact
tracing and I like to call it precision
social distancing where you identify the
people who are exposed get them tested
and then if they have the disease you
isolate them from the rest of society so
the rest of society can go on its way we
missed that boat and so now we've
basically put up social roadblocks so
that nobody interacts with each other to
the degree that's possible but on the
way back down right once we've sort of
gotten through the peak of the curve
we have to be able to move from mass
social distancing to precision social
distancing so that we don't have another
spike in and all of us have to go back
into our homes again form a social
distancing so that really is the next
stage we are unfortunately not on our
way there what that looks like is you
have in every community an army of
people who are ready to go to contact
everybody who might have been exposed
from anybody who has kovat 19 so the
minute there is a Cova 19 case you sit
down with that person and say tell me
all of the people with whom you've come
in contact over the last 14 days and
it's a whole systematic approach right
let's start with yesterday where were
you yesterday who this is the kind of
thing that an ideal world we would have
been doing back in January and February
when people were starting to reenter the
country and I want to share an
experience I have family members in Asia
and when they landed in Asia they were
escorted straight to their apartment and
said you're gonna stay here for two
weeks we're then gonna put a monitor on
your door we're gonna have a government
employee show up every day and take your
temperature and also by the way make
sure you're still home and there are
real problems if you're not home now I I
sent a tweet just factually relaying
what they were doing over there and you
know I got some reactions being like
well that could never happen in America
but ideally that is what we would have
been doing to people back in the day in
January and February and you're
suggesting that that's what we're going
to try and do now for people who have
confirmed cases after the curb declines
we wouldn't have had to go that hard
right you we wouldn't have had to
necessarily do enforced quarantine
adjust for anybody who gets off a plane
but yeah for people who are exposed to
somebody who has the disease you got to
get them tested and between when they
get tested and when the test results
you've got us you've got to make sure
that they stay home and so we have to
start being able to identify people and
then be able to enforce isolation to
be able to go to precision social
distancing so that were not all self
isolating at home I think about an
epidemic like a fire I just want to stop
for a second here man did you like you
must have studied this [ __ ] in school
big time like there must have been this
whole freaking crazy set a unit sod like
the Spanish flu and the pandemic and the
pandemics of the future and all that
stuff yeah I mean that's the the keyword
and epidemiologist is epidemic you know
if you've got a if you've got a toaster
fire you know you need to put it out and
if you can't put it out in the toaster
it's going to take over the house
and if you don't put it on the house
it's gonna take over the neighborhood
but imagine all of the stuff we do to
prevent fires right we've got fire
alarms in our houses we've got fire
stations in our neighborhoods
imagine you were to take the batteries
out of the fire alarm you were to fir
load the entire firefighting staff what
do you think is gonna happen when the
toaster catches fire and this is exactly
where we were and so we have created a
society where not only did we actively
shut down the capacity to respond in
real-time and put out outbreaks when
they were small but we've also as you
talked quite a bit about we've created a
society where people were left
exceedingly vulnerable to the economic
social political consequences of
something like this happening and so we
were not prepared we were not ready and
it's devastating
[Music]
when you go online they're watching
who's they unfortunately a lot of people
and you know here on yang speaks were
big fans of our data being ours and of
data rights and of data privacy we
started the data dividend project to
fight for your data rights but in the
meantime what can you do so that when
you go online internet service providers
aren't keeping track of that data and
then selling it so what can you do about
it
incognito mode unfortunately doesn't
work quite as well as you hope it would
so what you can do is what a lot of
companies do for their employees you can
use a virtual private network now the
one that we recommend your yang speaks
is expressvpn it's an app that reroutes
your internet connection through their
secure servers so your ISP can't see the
sites you visit it keeps all your
information secure by encrypting a
hundred percent of your data with the
most powerful encryption available you
click one button you forget about it you
don't even realize you have it on it's
like all of your devices are just
getting piped through this fancy fun new
network that you can call your own
protect your online activity today with
the VPN rated number one by C net and
wired visit my exclusive link expressvpn
comm slash yang and you can get an extra
three months free on a one-year package
that's exp our ESS VPN dot-com slash
yang expressvpn com slash young to learn
more keep your data safe and secure
[Music]
if you had guidance for people who are
right now trying to write out this
crisis something practical immediate
helpful what would it be I'd say number
one just remember that the only way
around this is through it
you can't just magically open up the
economy again and expect that people are
just gonna go out because you said it's
okay
so long as there's a real risk of
transmission of disease and doing that
people are gonna avoid it that's number
one number two is hard like this is just
really really really hard and I think
one of the most important things we can
do is try to allay some of the
psychological challenge of this by
reaching out engaging with people trying
to find the silver linings in this cloud
and and making sure that for us social
distancing doesn't mean social isolation
and then lastly stay home right the that
the most important thing we can do as a
society is protect each other and one of
the things this is teaching us something
you've talked a lot about your campaign
is that we are all as vulnerable as the
most vulnerable of us we're all as
exposed as the most exposed of us and so
we've all got to do our part to
eliminate the spread of disease every
time that virus replicates that's more
virus in the world and a higher
probability that we or someone we love
is gonna get sick and so being able to
find that patience by building the
semblance of normal in this moment I
think is just really critical yeah I
couldn't agree more you know to me the
government should be protecting us
against events that are very low
probability and a particular day but
high probability over time that have
high impact you know like this pandemic
something like this is obviously not
occurred in our in our lifetime but I
know in your books this was eminently
predictable this is something that
experts have been trying to warn us
about for years people have seen it
coming and so you can't know what's
gonna happen in 2019 and 2020 I
certainly you know like people have been
talking about how my call for universal
basic income was ahead of the curve and
I I'd be the first to say look you know
like I wasn't running around like
warning about
[Laughter]
of our jobs one of the things I've said
is that we're going through 10 years
worth of change in 10 weeks in the
economy in many respects like the things
I was most concerned about are
accelerating and one of the things you
just touched on is the mental health
crisis we're in the midst of to me it's
going to end up having a disastrous
effect on many people's mental health
already is yeah yeah the the use of the
crisis text line has already more than
doubled as one data point and the
proportion of asian-americans using the
crisis text line shot up from 5% it's
like the percentage of the population
age Americans are so it's pretty normal
to is like 13% last I checked yeah so
that so it surged and this is something
that well I'd love to pick your brain
about because they you know everything
has its own set of circumstances but
reading your book it was very affecting
how you were in high school when 9/11
happened and you just like we're like oh
my gosh like that the entire perception
of Muslim Americans has been changed by
this event now certainly they're
different in many respects I mean our
everything is different but I will say
that the closest analogue I can think of
to the fact that now Asian Americans are
perceived as responsible for the virus
was in your own experience as a Muslim
American post 9/11 mm-hmm yeah no I am
it is devastating to watch as people who
are doing nothing but trying to protect
themselves and their families from what
we're all trying to protect ourselves
and our families from are now being hit
with the added burden of discrimination
simply as a function of what they look
like and and where their families come
from and yeah I remember being a junior
in high school when 9/11 happened and I
you know I remember was the beginning of
the school year right so you're still
excited about about school starting and
you're just getting into your groove and
for for me you know was the first time
that I went from being you know brown
guy with a funny name to being a very
particular kind of brown guy with a very
particular kind of funny name and then
all of a sudden right everybody sort of
knew all of the epithets they knew all
of the stereotypes no for our family in
particular my little brother who's eight
years younger than I am his name is
Osama oh my gosh wait if you're a junior
in high school that makes you like 16
years old he's like eight you eat yeah
yeah oh no yeah that would have been
brutal brutal I'm sure at some point he
even thought about like maybe I should
like go by another name did you like
adopt another Nick you know to his
credit my parents asked him they said
you know you can go by Sam we'll just
start calling you Sam he said no my name
is Osama that's what you named me and
that's my name and I'm proud of it you
know just it was it was a sort of a
moment of just being like you know
that's uh it takes a lot for an
eight-year-old who was getting bullied
left and right my brother is also kind
of like your brother he's just one of
those really really good nice people and
his response when he'd get bullied for
his name and of course it still happens
wasn't to lash out wasn't to hit back
his response almost always was just this
like extremely emotionally mature
response which was you know when you say
that it really hurts my feelings and it
just diffuses everything right people
are just that when they hear that they
like on I'm sorry man like I didn't I
didn't mean hurt your feelings it's just
so I mean emotionally mature beyond
beyond his years he said you know I'm
not I'm not ashamed of Who I am and what
my name is and and I'm proud of my name
in Arabic it means lion-hearted and in
fact my parents my name my full name is
Abdul Rahman it's 11 letters long and
nobody can say it so I became Abdul
before I started preschool because that
was you know 1989 and Paula Abdul was a
thing and Kareem abdul-jabbar was a
thing and then eight years later they
had my little brother and they're like
you know we got to give him an easier
name so let's just do Sam with on the
front and a on the back and so like my
parents are over to on boys names but
yeah it was it went from all of a sudden
being different to being a very
particular kind of different and you
knew exactly what the stereotypes were
going to be and how it was gonna hit you
and so you know my heart goes out to
Asian American folks in our communities
who have to bear this and I'm just
deeply sorry and I'll tell you this
whenever and if ever I see it I want to
call it out and I think all of us should
make that commitment to call it out
because it's wrong it's dangerous and
it's hurtful and it's something we need
to always constantly be doing work to
root out in our societies
now when I think about the people are
affected for whatever reason I just keep
thinking about this Chinese family I met
in Iowa where they just ran like the
local Chinese buffet and they were very
very sweet people and right now I'm sure
every restaurant in that town is closed
but I have this sinking feeling that
even after restaurants reopen that that
family's business is going to be worse
than it was and then that's gonna play
out across China towns around the
country around you know those like
ethnic food Mart's that I personally
love whenever I see like an Asian food
market you probably say wait like
probably like what you see it's like
sort I think food markets we just run in
and there's like goo with it you get
like four or five things from your
childhood ever mind you of that fact
like I have this sinking feeling that
all of those businesses are going to
suffer because people are just going to
not want to go to that restaurant that
Chinatown that community that food
market and I I think it's going to
persist do you have any tips for folks
who are like new to this you know I am
you know I think I think certainly
people of color in our country have have
experienced this for a long time and
also you know it's important to call out
that Cova 19 has had a disproportionate
impact on black Americans and Native
Americans and so we're seeing structural
racism play out in a number of ways yeah
that's happening right in Michigan right
I think I just saw the stat where
African Americans are at 13% of the
state of Michigan but 40% of the death
so far that's right
that's right and so you know I don't
know that that I can share anything that
other folks haven't already experienced
or thought through but what I will say
is number one we all have a choice about
where and how we spend our money and so
if you've got an ethnic Rocher in your
community who you think is going to be
in trouble because of the I hate to say
the Xena phobia and the discrimination
in a community make sure you go spend
your buck out there right that's that's
a simple thing that all of us can do
number two I think you know the impact
of this is so much more disproportionate
on young people because it frames the
way that they think about themselves and
I
one of the most important things that we
can do is make sure that we're
constantly empowering young people who
face discrimination on a daily basis and
reminding them that they're beautiful
that they're meaningful that they matter
that they have power and that we are
proud of them right because that's where
they get their own sense of their pride
and their value and their sense of
belonging and then number three that I
in my life used to respond to a lot of
this by hitting back and I found that
just over time that yeah just so you
know I don't know people I can see you
I've duel right now but Abdul seems like
pugnacious type terms of like he's like
played football I think in high school
and like that's right yeah like
certainly I could very easily see like
if someone gave you [ __ ] dye school
you'd be like all right let's see I hate
to say it sometimes in my first reaction
but it's never my best reaction well I
think I think part of it's just like
where you are you know in terms of your
maturation stage like because I can
imagine high school you would just hit
back immediately yeah College probably
say the same but I mean at this point
you're like a dad like you've been like
the head of the Department of Health the
city of Detroit and you pretty much have
to learn to have a very thick skin at
some point the other thing you start to
appreciate is that people who engage in
this form of behavior oftentimes they do
it because they've given themselves
license to try and take away your
humanity and I think you know if I
learned anything my little brother is
that in that response when he would say
you know that hurts my feelings what he
was doing was very very clearly
asserting his humanity people have
feelings right and if you're able to
look at somebody and say you know what
you said really hurt my feelings it
forces a certain empathy because all of
us have had our feelings hurt and I just
think that there is a space to ask why
are you saying what you're saying and
how can I show you that what you're
saying actually it defiles you just like
it just like you think it defiles me and
if we can grapple with forcing people to
come to terms with the mutual shared
humanity that all of us have in this
moment
I think we're all the better for it
right and then the other thing is one of
the points that my mom used to always
make is that now at some point you can
only control you and you can ask
yourself what did you do in that moment
to bring out the best in someone and
obviously when someone's being racist
and discriminatory they're not their
best and you know some would say well
you know what I don't owe them anything
and that's true you don't but I think
there is always an opportunity to ask
how do I bring my best in a situation
and how do I pull out even the shred of
what's what's good in that person that's
left like alright so I've got an
opportunity to engage someone who's not
being their best can I bring my best to
bring out their best because if you can
do that right that's the kind of person
who truly changes things that constant
ask it's a hard thing to do and
certainly if you don't if you choose not
to do it no harm no foul I don't blame
you but there is a real opportunity
there and that opportunity is worth
taking I think that's a beautiful
sentiment and I know that's not just you
know your brother's example I mean like
I know you've been a leader and role
model one of the things in your story
that impressed me the most there were a
lot of a very impressive things but so
you're married in New York you're a
professor at Columbia and then you wound
up dropping everything to go back to
Detroit to run the Department of Health
that at that point was really poorly
resourced you know you had to like go
and you had to be apart from your wife
that to me is in many ways the biggest
testament to your spirit of service
because you and I know a lot of people
who came through the meritocracy and had
like the opportunity to teach it at Ivy
League universities and one not and not
many of them do what you did well I
appreciate your saying that I my parents
who raised me or my stepmom was a
daughter of the American Revolution and
my father who was an immigrant from
Alexandria Egypt and I'd spent a lot of
my summers in Alexandria with my
grandmother who never got to go to
school despite being one of the wisest
people I've ever met and she made a
habit of reminding me that
there was nothing special about me there
was only something special about my
opportunity she point out one cousin and
be like you know that was smarter than
you point out to another one she said
that ones is better-looking than you
point out to a third one that was taller
than you and her point was that you owe
your opportunities a responsibility and
I think you know that that's one of the
best things about being the child of
immigrants is that I know exactly what
opportunities I had because I saw the
contrapositive and so the crazy thing is
that on those trips to Egypt I would
travel about 15 hours and travel about
ten years difference in life expectancy
and I could travel the same ten year
life expectancy gap in 25 minutes if I
were to leave my suburban Detroit home
and drive to any neighborhood in Detroit
and that always framed why I became a
doctor in the first place the work that
I wanted to do and so when I got the
opportunity to come home and rebuild a
department that had been shut down when
the city went through bankruptcy you
know for me that was just that that's
the responsibility I owed the
opportunities that I was given and so
it's easy to get too complex about your
your personal calculations right should
I do this should I do that but for me
that the simple litmus test is what
would my take I think right what would
she say about what I chose to do and
whether or not it was worthy of the very
unique opportunities that I got and so
that's why I did it I hope that that
focus remains always for me that sense
of dignifying your opportunity because
uses something you talked about quite a
bit in your work and ruin something I
really admired about the clarity of your
run is that at the end of the day you
your privilege is always creating
privilege somewhere you're either
increasing privilege for people who
already have it or you're providing a
modicum for people who don't and like
that's the choice so you know you you
work up the meritocracy you you get you
get knighted by all these institutions
who put their seal of approval on you
and the question you have to ask
yourself is well is what you're doing
you know what the [ __ ] was that for
[Laughter]
well well see here's the thing if I say
to someone hey Abdul or
dr. twice over Abdul el Syed goes home
to Detroit run the Department of Health
people say okay like that sounds very
like important and official but
I know what the reality is just like you
know what the reality is where you like
show up in Detroit you have this
skeleton crew in the back of the parking
office like the hospital that used to
house it is shuttered your first task as
like the person trying to increase
people's life expectancy is to deal with
a vagrant dog problem because the
freakin dogs are like roaming the
streets of Detroit and I've spent a lot
of time in Detroit even I didn't know
that one I was like what like you had a
freaking you know it's like that's like
the official storybook version and then
there's like the real-life version right
and I know what the real-life version
looked like having spent enough time in
that city I was working I was working
probably 110 120 hour weeks I got a
little studio in downtown and I'd be in
the office by 8:00 I'd leave the office
by 9:00 or 10:00 and I would do that six
to seven days a week and like the only
time that I wasn't there I was in New
York where I would generally you know be
with Sara but like if she was a she was
a resident physician and so she had
weekend hours and you know I would need
to get out and just keep working because
things kept going there were a lot of
days where I was like what are we doing
here
it's just impossible you're right like
you know you walk in and you've got five
city employees 85 contractors in the
back of the building where people go to
pay parking tickets in the poorest city
in America and you know I had to like
wrangle money out of the city using the
state by digging into like the state law
about what the city should be investing
in public health yeah that was one of
the really impressive things about your
story because you show up and you have
[ __ ] for resources and then you're like
um and they get some more resources like
I've got it there's like a freakin
statute here that I could use to like
you know bully some more money and and
that's the thing is like but that's
Detroit right like that's the it is the
most resilient gritty place you'll ever
go and Detroiters just have this like
incredible never-say-die attitude I
don't know if folks have been watching
the last dance about the Jordan years
with the Bulls but like you know the
real story of 90s basketball is the bad
boy pistons and
the bad-boy pistons are like the best
example of what Detroit grit is all
about like yeah you know what we're
probably less talented than you right
probably less funded than you but you
know what we are going to outwork you
out hustle you and beat the [ __ ] out of
you and that's how we're gonna win and
like that was just it was it was this
this this moment of just saying alright
so you know how do we build a team out
of the folks who are here how do we
believe in what we can accomplish and
then how do we go out there and be
scrappy and make things happen with the
focus on protecting our most vulnerable
yeah I'll be honest I you know I've done
a number of things since but I don't
know that I'll ever be as fulfilled in a
job as I was in those moments at the
health department because it was the
thrill of doing something unique for
people who really really needed it and
rarely is work that unencumbered morally
yeah it'd be so pure you're literally
it's like hey I'm just here to try and
make your kid's life longer and
healthier and and one of the stories I
loved in your book is that you just sort
of show up people's doorsteps on like
Friday afternoons being like hey like
what's going on like what's going wrong
in your neighborhood one of the things
that broke my heart was the fact that
you identified that demolishing
buildings in Detroit actually
contributed to an increased risk of lead
poisoning for the kids who are near the
demolished houses because so Detroit
peak population 1.7 million right
current population approximately six
hundred eighty thousand something along
those lines so the thing is almost
two-thirds empty so you look around and
the way Detroit's laid out is that it's
a fairly large area it's not like Allan
Manhattan it's like super densely
populated it's like fairly spread out
it's huge you could fit all of Boston
Manhattan and San Francisco and Detroit
and still have room left over yeah yeah
so it's kind of spread out and it's
almost two-thirds empty so you have all
these buildings that are derelict
hazardous blighted so the fact that they
were trying to demolish them I was for
the fact that unfortunately the building
materials had lead paint on them such
that if you demolish and let dust goes
up and
probably ends up increasing health risks
for people for blocks around
particularly vulnerable kids I was like
oh no I got it's like real sinking
feeling and the fact you identified that
you know to me was so profound because I
know the people in charge were very
excited about demolishing some buildings
and that's the thing the demolitions
weren't the problem when you demolish at
that scale it's almost impossible to
hold all of the contractors who are
actually doing the demolishing
accountable and so you know of course
they're going to cut corners and they're
going to cheat and when they do that
means that the lead that was you know
packed away in the inside of those homes
gets out and you know you got a kid
playing outside or a kid opening the
window and trying to study in the room
that's gonna get in their lungs and that
has consequences and unfortunately when
we analyzed it that's what we found and
so it was really frustrating right
because you know this is a high profile
program a program that has a lot of
money going into it and no nobody wants
to hear bad news but this sort of gets
to the beginning of the conversation
that we had Andrew which is in public
health the hard part about public health
is that if you're allowed and you ring
the alarm bells right people are like
yeah this is it's not a big deal right
it's gonna be just fine and if you're
quiet then bad things happen and so
you're constantly fighting a losing
battle and here we are in the middle of
a corona virus pandemic that really is
the same story Alex a czar for all of
the things I disagree with him on right
tried to turn ring the alarm bells about
this pandemic well before it became a
global pandemic and they shouted him
down right they shush them up and here
we are and so you know I know that
experience right I literally got called
Cassandra by the higher-ups in the
office because every time I'd come in
I'd be like look I've got bad news for
you and let me tell you how this is
gonna hurt kids and they'd be like oh
well you know yeah well
[Music]
let's say you are creative and you want
to get better and you are stuck at home
sort of like now Skillshare is a way
that you can actually learn from people
who are better than you at whatever
creative skill you're trying to develop
and you can access them in real time
online it's really hecka cool it's like
the creative community you've always
wanted and dreamed that you can access
from the comfort of your own home so a
friend of mine actually was the
co-founder of Skillshare and he's like
this he was very much like this like
creative nerd and we just wanted to nerd
out so if you're creative nerd you need
to use skill share and if you're not a
creative nerd and you're just a nerd or
you're just creative it's still pretty
cool too so if you go to Skillshare comm
slash yang they're gonna give you two
free months - yang speak listeners so
you can play around this for two months
learn everything you want and if you
like you keep going and it's a pretty
sweet deal yeah if you get two months I
mean you'll be able to figure out if
it's awesome but it is pretty awesome
like there are so many folks who go
there and just get addicted frankly and
it's like a positive addiction it's not
like a negativity right it's like you're
just learning you're like learning
addictions are bettering yourself
yeah learning addiction you get two
months for free if you're gonna scale
traitor icon slash getting unlimited
access so you can just go hog-wild
maybe you can just guru up in two months
and then you will be like I have all of
the skills it'll be like neo and matrix
you like plug-in and being like I know
Adobe what's real Skillshare calm slash
gang check it out - three months
[Music]
[Applause]
reading your book when you talk about
the epidemic of insecurity I could not
agree more and my solution as you know
as everyone knows probably listening to
this is like hey I think we should give
everyone money I think that would that
would actually really help more quickly
and dramatically than just about
anything else we could do and and one
thing I love about your experience is
like you have like the obviously like
the very very high level academic
training but then you also were like on
the ground you were literally not just
like near the boots on the ground you
were the boots on the ground you know
just like walk into someone's home and
be like hey turns out you don't have
running water cuz the city shut it down
like well that's probably not very good
for your health and even your comment
about the contractors like you see how
muddy the reality is where of course if
you assign someone to demolish the house
you'd be like you know you should do we
can tarp the whole thing like you know
go through all these precautions and
then in real life when they're at that
house like you know if their tarp tears
they'll be like yeah that's like house
number number five for the day guys just
want to go home right and they're like
you know what maybe maybe house number
five is not gonna be that bad you're
like well there's a kid who lives next
door and it's just just as important as
house number one right just because it's
your fifth house for the day and so like
there's a way that human nature gets in
the way and I think the best
policymaking is policy that that is able
to anticipate and appreciate how human
nature works
yes addresses that yeah I'm there too
man like as one of the things like you
and I have so much in common like I
completely share your passion for the
fact that we have an epidemic of
insecurity across food health community
family financial stability you name it
at this point Culture Media I mean like
we're really in the [ __ ]
like and many of these things and your
numbers guide to it's like I see one fun
thing about reading your book was like
you just busted out like a bunch of
measurements that demonstrate the
epidemic of its security and like all
these dimensions and I'm like yeah yeah
yeah it's like it like I'm
under percent with you and then the
question is how the heck do we turn that
around the other thing I share with
actually I don't share this with you
you're better than me on this is that
like you stuck your nose right into the
grindstone of like the workings of
health care institutions government like
you got in there and and one of the
things you said in your book that really
impressed me because I've thought it was
that like you're a doctor seeing
patients and then you're like this
shit's not gonna do it like that you
know I mean it's like we introduced so
many people in those situations where
they're supposed to go in with a certain
ambition we set them up so they're like
you know a piece of a bigger machine and
on some level they have to realize it's
like you know this is not actually
aligned with like my original goal set
but at this point I'm here like you know
like that they're paying me to do X I'm
just gonna do it well to be fair and do
I remember getting a phone call I think
it was in December of 2018 from a guy
named Andrew yang who was like yo I'm
running for president I was like you're
gonna do what it's like I'm running for
president and I remember asking you why
and you said look I have been working in
this nonprofit space trying to get
people to realize the basic truth of the
fact that we cannot solve this by
tinkering at the edges of the policy
that that currently exists and I'm
running because I believe in this idea
of freedom dividend so millions of
people around our country agree with you
and that's largely because you had the
courage to step up and make them issues
so grateful to you for that and I think
for the long-term right even just
short-term right people are getting
$1,200 checks and in some respects
that's an idea that's on the table that
was on the table because of your work so
I think change is halting and sometimes
it doesn't end up in people being in the
positions to make change but by putting
ideas into the ether and driving a
conversation that refocuses where we
ought to be focused I think that makes a
big difference so thank you for doing
your part I really appreciate it
oh man that's so kind of you I remember
that conversation too and you and I had
though obviously again I had this
conversation because we didn't win our
respective races but I do feel like we
helped move
certain ideas closer to fruition in your
case there's obviously universal health
care and in part because of your
background and then there's a new kind
of politics and this is not the word you
use is actually like cory booker thing
but like reading a book i actually
thought of it's like more of like a
politics of humanity or a politics of
love it's a little bit like how you
talked about responding to racism where
it's like if someone comes at you like
they're trying to dehumanize you and you
have to try and almost rehumanize
yourself to them to the extent that it's
possible and that is what our politics
needs alright so I suppose I'm gonna
just throw it out to you it's like what
is your universal basic income there's
something where you're like hey you know
what like there's there are a couple of
things I'm going to make sure people
understand more fully we know or lose
it's gonna be this set of ideas yeah so
my big policy focus has been Medicare
for all just because that's the area in
which I work you know the next book I
got a book coming out in February on
Medicare for all co-written with a
friend of mine I'll take you write
another book when this book just came
out like a minute ago man that seems
crazy and real you'll see the the world
after having lost a campaign is long
there's a lot of time you get to spend
just writing stuff Medicare for all for
me is is just it's fundamentally
critical because it speaks to two issues
at the same time a lot of folks focus on
Medicare for all as it's just about
getting people health care it is it is
absolutely but one of the things that
this pandemic has shown us is that our
for-profit health care system is not
geared up to be able to provide quality
health care at scale in the moments when
we need it most
and it's not just about providing people
health care but it's also about
reforming the incentives in the health
care system so that were constantly
focused on the bottom line of people's
well-being yes I love it I can't wait
for you to explain this more fully and I
know I want to read your next book just
as bad as as this book so the the dream
to me is that if someone's healthy and
doesn't see a health care provider in
that year then that's like a huge
success that like right right now
unfortunately the way we're
during performances often just in how
much revenue gets generated by the
hospital the drug company etc etc and in
in reality we should be trying to
measure how people are doing and if the
company wasn't necessary then that
should somehow actually be rewarding
them at a higher level mm-hmm and that's
that's the thing right you're exactly
right it's like sometimes there are
goods and services that we should not
measure in monetary terms and a person's
health and well-being is exactly that
right because like if you're the average
individual and you're lucky enough to
have been born healthy right we want the
system to keep you healthy
not just reward providing you health
care and unfortunately that's the system
that we have right now and it has
fundamentally failed us in in the middle
of this pandemic I mean your books
talking about like it was failing us
before this pandemic but you don't even
need the pandemic oh yeah and that's the
things like it's failing us all at once
in this pandemic and this is also why I
don't like it when we talk about going
back to normal me neither because normal
just wasn't very normal for a lot of
folks right yeah yeah so I am a hundred
percent with you on the dysfunction of
our current healthcare system the fact
that we spend more than other countries
to worse results the fact that it's
highly uneven the fact it's
incentivizing the wrong behaviors the
fact that we have doctors that are
prescribing things for their own
institutional self-interest or legal
self-protection and that's not entirely
their fault it's like you know we have a
system that that's just like hey if you
get the extra test like can't be sued so
you know go ahead and do it and then you
you have that you know times millions of
patients the thing that I was trying to
figure out even in the midst of my
campaign was how the heck we get from
this current kludgy jacked up terrible
system with the wrong incentives to like
a system that would work and I had some
ideas as to how we could move us there
but I would absolutely love to hear your
vision as someone who's worked deeply in
the system yeah I so any transition of a
sector that accounts for 20% of your
economy is going to be less smooth than
you would like but I will say a couple
of things number one
I do think that there's an ability to
roll it out in time in a way that
provides the insurance coverage to those
who need it most so you know you start
with kids and then from there you grow
it to young adults and then from there
you pull it down to those 55 and older
and then from there you just close the
gap but then the other part of this is
also you've got a huge insurance
infrastructure that exists right now we
know that about 15% of that insurance
infrastructure doesn't necessarily add
value so it doesn't like it literally
removes value like it's there the whole
purpose is to like deny people coverage
yeah yeah so I mean in general they're
they're like a giant tax on us yeah so
how do you take that and say well look
if we were to extend the healthcare
coverage to the 10% of Americans who are
now locked out of the system there's
gonna be a whole lot more healthcare
jobs that we need is there a way for us
as this is happening right to be
providing a staged efficient
well-managed well compensated transition
from the part of the healthcare system
that's used to deny people care right
now
to the part of the healthcare system
that actually offers people care when
they need it right is there a way for us
to like manage that transition and then
for the rest of the infrastructure that
exists is there a way to bake it in
because there's you know folks don't
appreciate this but even Medicare it
runs through a shell of industry that
takes very very very tiny margins but
then still operates through the private
industrial health insurance model so
that part of the model doesn't have to
go away it just gets administered
differently and for those jobs that are
not going to be necessary in a system
that doesn't actively prevent people
from getting the payments for the
healthcare that they need is there a way
for us to manage so that instead of
being in a job where you're denying
people healthcare you're in a job where
you're providing it and I think you know
there's also a thought of saying well
what if Medicare for all was also
administered parallel at the state level
right where you end up having an
expansion of state level provided health
insurance where you then have these
learnings happening at every state that
you have CMS centrally potentially
taking best practices and acting almost
like a consulting arm that empowers
communities to build up there so CMS is
your is your michigan version of CMS is
the centers for medicare and medicaid
right there the folks who administer
medicare as it is but in michigan right
we have healthy Michigan is the plan
right it's the state Medicaid plan but
you can imagine sort of a fully
empowered fully resourced stood-up
system where you basically have a
michigan level insurance program for
everybody
medicare for all but laid out in
parallel across the state level do you
think that's preferable like having
state-by-state effort towards Medicare
for all
so we're I think there's some real
benefit to that is you end up having
instead of one major rollout that risks
going poorly kind of like healthcare.gov
you have 50 rollouts right and they're
all administered in parallel and then
the federal government basically becomes
a resource driver and consulting arm for
best practices the other thing is it
allows you for some local control
because you do have huge demographic
differences across states yeah the
danger though right is just like you've
seen with some of the southern state
governments who have been reticent to
take the hand out of Medicaid expansion
[Music]
what do you do a third of your life
ideally sleep what are you doing on a
mattress what do you need a mattress
that you can sleep on and happily keep
Blake's sleep offers just that it's a
high-end mattress and they send you in a
box you just busted that out and then
snuggle up on a pillow I think they
throw a free pillow into this action and
they've won awards they were like the
overall mattress pick of 2019 and 2020
by GQ and Wired magazine so you know
there was some wired editor to sleeping
on these mattresses being like this is
the one what a giddy
they chose helix sleep and we to our
fans just going to helix sleep calm /
yeah take their two minutes sleep quiz
we just fun because you get to answer
questions about how your sleep and
they'll match you with a customized
mattress that gives you the best sleep
of your life what is the best sleep of
your life feel like I don't know but you
can find out and they'll give you a ten
your warranty you can try it out for a
hundred nights you can sleep on that
mattress for three months risk-free and
I'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will that's a lot
of confidence in this mattress so good I
like sleeping calm and they're offering
$200 off all Baptists orders - three
pillars for our listeners at helix sleep
comm slash that's helix ATX sleep I just
did this I took the quiz you put in your
name you can put in your partner's name
you can choose a side that you want
that's firm or soft and you sleep on
your back you sleep on your side you
have back pain in the morning do you not
and they this magical wheel spins and
then it tells you mattress to order and
then they ship it to you in a box and a
bed frame and if you use our code you
get two free pillows and two hundred
hours off so it is as easy as advertised
it's beautiful it's comfortable it's
simple helix leap comm slashing 200 off
I think most Americans right now realize
we need to take a very very different
approach to health care than that we've
had
so hopefully this pandemic will have at
least that silver lining where the
consensus towards some kind of universal
health care plan will grow overwhelming
because I can't imagine someone in this
period of time still being but you know
it's like oh yeah like this current
market-based private insurance system is
working great like I just can't imagine
someone feeling that way after this
pandemic no I think you're entirely
right and I mean we've we've watched as
the health care system has been brought
to its knees by this pandemic and I
think Americans realized that we've got
to do something about it
well Abdul your book healing politics I
got a lot out of it I think you're an
incredible role model and American hero
and I learned a lot from it tell us what
it is that you're working on aside from
I'm sure promoting this book because I
have a publisher too and you know that
publisher like wants to know that you're
out there but what are you working on
aside from this book tour yeah well got
a couple of things going I run a
political action committee called
southpaw in Michigan folks can check it
out at southpaw my calm and we're really
gearing up we sort of run a reverse
coattails approach where we're really
focused on really really high quality
local candidates and we know that if
folks come out and support local
candidates they'll come out and support
candidates at the top of the ticket as
well and then I am doing a bit of
teaching I've got another book I'm
working on and then of course working
with you on CNN and I host a podcast
called
America dissected where we go beyond the
headlines on the health care issues of
the day but it's a privilege to be on
with you I really appreciate it and it's
been fun getting to know each other
really grateful for your leadership and
your run and I really look forward to
what we're going to do next
all right thank you so much all the best
of the family man stay safe you too my
best Avila in the kids okay
[Music]